hello everyone and welcome to batman v
superman uh batman versus superman the
other one's a movie this show is
actually called versus i host it my name
is mark and this is the program where we
take movies tv and performers and make
them compete against each other for our
amusement i'm just looking at all the
guys faces here in the control tower i'm
good i'm good to me yeah as long as
they're best friends and yep i think
we're cool with that now sometimes you
might say art is art and should only be
judged on its own merit and that
argument doesn't really fly today
because we have the greatest superheroes
of all time and they've already shown
their desire to beat one another to a
pulp so let's run it back boy you are in
for a show tonight son no mom names can
save you now it's bruce wayne taking on
clark kent and batman slugging it out
against superman and here come the
comments yes i did refer to them as the
greatest heroes ever why because they
are i love the mcu and it's fun seeing
spider-man swing around on all those
adorable multiverses but according to
comic book sales superman and batman are
still number one and two all time in
that order they had a nice little head
start but that makes the relevance today
all the more impressive they're almost a
century old each and they still have
beef with each other in one corner you
have the alien fella from krypton his
home planet blew up he came to earth and
on his chest he wears the symbol for
hope which is apparently spelled
differently in kryptonian other breaking
news
water wet in the other corner it's the
kid who saw his parents get murdered got
a sweet inheritance and used it to bring
gotham city's worst offenders to justice
and is now gonna be played by robert
pattinson on the big screen we're still
waiting for news about superman i have
no idea what's going on listen it isn't
that i don't trust you but
i i don't trust you but i do know that
clark and bruce have been pals enemies
frenemies and co-workers and now they go
mono amano for the right to claim
stand-alone superhero supremacy here's
how we'll determine a winner round one
box office round two tomato meter slash
audience score round three origin of the
species round four dastardly deeds
and then we'll do a wild card round that
batman hopes will involve gadgets and
superman hopes does not involve neon
green stuff before we ring the bell in
this epic heavyweight slobberdocker
let's take a moment to remember all that
these two do have in common uh they love
justice they love their moms their dads
are done so billowing capes they fought
against oscar winners and both have been
played by ben affleck
i've been a little busy
kinda i'll explain later okay enough
pleasantries superman is here on a
mission to prove that he is earth's
mightiest hero and batman wants to
avenge the loss he took last season on
this show to iron man you
filthy criminal let's get it on
round one box office
any weirdo cape can save a few lives
here and there i did it yesterday but it
takes a hero to do it consistently and
it requires a superhero to do it while
millions of people are forking over
billions of dollars in hard-earned cash
to witness them do it that's the case
with bats and soups and their film
lineage dates all the way back to 1966.
the super bowl wasn't called that yet
the beatles were in pre-production of
that peter jackson documentary and adam
west was playing batman with bert ward
as robin you risked your life to save
that riffraff in the bar
they may be drinkers robin but they're
also human beings we don't have accurate
box office information for that film's
release since back then you could get a
ticket with a stick of gum or a jaunty
tune holy heart failure so instead let's
earmark 1978.
that's when we would believe a man could
fly because superman the movie told us
so
easy miss i've got you you you've got me
who's got you christopher eve and margot
kidder starred as clark and lois lane
what more could anyone ask
and richard donner was at the helm for
the film that became a worldwide
phenomenon even more important than its
cineplex receipts which adjusted for
inflation equals in excess of 500
million domestically it was proof that
earth was ready to take a superhero
movie seriously this wasn't just kid
stuff it was for all ages when i was six
years old my father said to me get out
eleven years later batman would
reiterate that claim as michael keaton
donned the cape and cow for tim burton's
first foray into gotham city what are
you
i'm batman
the flake dominated the summer of 1989
taught this chubby kid that you could
buy nachos at the concession stand
gentlemen
let's broaden our minds and cinema was
changed forever again oh and it raked in
close to 600 million dollars
domestically when adjusted for inflation
which i will do for all these numbers so
i don't have to keep saying that phrase
over and over again holy sardine keaton
would go on to make batman returns in
1992 then val kilmer took over the cape
in 1995's batman forever after which
george clooney grabbed the cow and the
nipples in 1997's batman and robin in
what has to be the loosest quadrilogy of
all time those three sequels combined
for almost 900 million dollars meow
meanwhile reeve had already ended his
run at superman by the time 1989 rolled
around but not before making three
sequels himself these were accurately
titled superman two
three and four the quest for peace how
can one man be so square and so
delicious and although they would amount
to over 500 million dollars total in
earth bucks the name of the game is
making money two and three did the
lion's share of that work part four only
earned 34 million dollars in 1987.
nobody's perfect and that's just
beginning of their story four more
superman starring live action flicks
awaited us but it was almost five and we
could have seen tim burton direct
nicholas cage in superman lives at least
we got a great documentary out of it by
the sweatiest of us all john schnepp as
for the movies that did see the theaters
superman returns saw brandon routh take
over the title role in 2006 before henry
cavill would don it for 2013's man of
steel and then batman be superman and
finally justice league b versus s set
the high bar of this crop earning 359
million dollars in the states and almost
900 million bucks around the globe and
while that's great for clark it's going
to help bruce out just as much
bvs is also the highest grosser batman
has had since
that little trilogy that christopher
nolan directed starring christian bale
is the dark knight hey that's the name
of one of those movies and it alone
crossed the one billion dollar global
mark look it's all a bit technical but
the
important thing is that my company's
future is secure domestically the nolan
trifecta of batman begins the dark
knight and the dark knight rises in
three days after shattering his back
collected over 1.5 billion dollars which
is gonna buy a lot of heating pads i
thought my jokes were bad so let's
crunch all these numbers like we're
superman compressing the batmobile into
guano dust looking at the entire sum of
superman's films dude has grossed 2.32
billion dollars at the talking picture
houses that makes for a per talking
average of 290 million dollars it's not
a whole lot it's been swell swell and
here's the heartbreaker that average
would have been up to 327 million
dollars if he just didn't go on that one
quest for peace the pompous fool he's
played right into our hands could that
be the untimely interception that gives
batman this round
uh bruce might not need it shame on you
no such thing his movies have totaled
5.54 billion bucks which is a ton even
for a super rich guy and that makes a
per film average of 388 million dollars
every time he washes his tights waiter
sir
of course thank you my pleasure thanks
so much
what and yes those figures include the
animated feature films the great mask of
the phantasm from 1993 and 2016's the
killing joke those two only made 10
million dollars combined on the big
screen yet bad guy is still nipping on
400 million dollar per movie's heels
always bet on black that's quite the
opening statement made by both comic
book legends for now batman doing all
those weighted pull-ups pays off he tops
superman in round one and it's one to
nothing i'm most grateful i wasn't aware
of that round two tomato meter slash
audience score more often than not we
line up around the block to see these
titans in action which is kind of silly
because we could have just gotten our
tickets and selected our seats on the
fandango app employee of the month box
checked not in this universe but
regardless of how we get into the
theater upon leaving we owe batman and
superman a debt of gratitude not for
saving our lives or defeating bad guys
but because they both legitimize
superhero movies for mass audiences and
in terms of critical reception i'm here
to help looking at the tomato meter
digits movie reviewers responded very
favorably to both clark and bruce on
their inaugural outings the first two
superman films are fresh and the first
fourth theatrically released batman
films are fresh dating all the way back
to 1966's batman the movie at 79 percent
holy murloc magician 1989's batman is 71
batman returns is 80
and before batman forever there was
1993's mask of the phantasm i owned it
on vhs if anyone wants to come over and
look for it
get those wonderful toys meanwhile
superman set the standard for either
property with a 94 percent and superman
two smells really good with an 85
percent better yet the audience scores
for each of these six movies so far is
fresh with the highest being you guessed
it mask of the phantasm that movie is
the bomb yo
there are very few people left in the
world who feel comfortable saying that
as is the entire batman the animated
series it was so good and that's the
great news the bad news neither
franchise would see the fresh light of
day again until 2005's batman begins
that film having an 84 is fine but it's
remarkable when you recall that batman
forever is at 38
and batman and robin plummeted to 12
percent this is why superman works alone
what could be lower than that
oh no really quest for peace
yep superman 4 is at 10
and superman 3 is 29
but the flying fellow would rebound with
2006's superman returns which did come
back to freshville with a 75
that was the most recent superman movie
that's fresh it's weird right because
man of steel just missed at 56
then batman v superman thudded at 29
and justice league landed with a 40
but at least with those last two movies
bats and supes can just blame the other
one right batman solo did have a better
run thanks to the dark knight equaling
1978 superman within 94
and the dark knight rises has an 87
because half that movie is pretty sweet
sorry to keep letting you down oh and
lego batman it's a great film taps into
the batman pathos in a ferociously funny
and frighteningly accurate kind of way i
am super proud
of myself and it's rewarded with a 90 on
the tomato meter that's my cross to bear
will our net in company they're pretty
great enough gregor you're the best fan
in case you didn't feel like doing math
at home because let's be honest wordle
is more fun
i mean i understand any of that don't
worry i did movies prominently featuring
superman average 52 percent of the
tomato meter and their audience score
hovers around 58
that's almost fresh not bad but batman
despite living in a filthy city worked
for 20 years and got
oh that
is fresh on both metrics his tomato
meter average is 63 percent and the
audience score measurement is 68
so again it's in a potable effort by the
man of steel but metropolis is no match
for gotham thus far the dark knight wins
round two and takes a commanding lead
two to nothing is that how a warp brain
like yours gets its kicks round three
origin of the species this round is
gonna be one by which crime hater had
the better origin story according to
their film lineage who had the tougher
go of it who tugged on our heartstrings
more and by all means who has the better
training montages what is the point of
all those push-ups if you can't even
lift a bloody log
bruce saw his parents murdered right in
front of him on the streets of gotham
when he was just a little boy and to
pour salt on that wound greedy studio
execs would make him relive that moment
every what five years since 1989 we get
it tommy and martha are dead at least
young bruce got a consolation prize lots
of money and a fancy butler that's a
good thing i left everything to you then
quite so so
and you can borrow the rose if you like
yet even though his wealth is stashing
the vault so big it would make scrooge
mcduck drown bruce wayne has never been
able to fully recover from such a tragic
event luckily for us he takes his pain
out on gotham's underbelly i don't feel
anything emotionally except for rage in
1989's batman it was a pre-joker jack
napier who did the nasty deed of
de-parenting bruce subsequent versions
would portray the assailant as a
desperate rogue criminal but in the end
it was the same effect bruce had a hole
in his heart that he continually tries
to mend with justice vengeance and
hanging upside down in the wee hours of
the morning meanwhile superman's parents
are also dead as is just about everyone
he ever loved on the homeworld of
krypton now he was just a little baby
but krypton like alderaan and melmac
before it was destroyed moments after a
ship departed that would jettison cal to
relative safety on earth and although
soup's parents are gone from a physical
standpoint he still has the impactful
life lessons narrated by either marlon
brando or russell crowe in his ear when
he needs them the most after suffering
such tragedies as utes both heroes kind
of won the lottery sure they were
devastated emotionally but for young
clark he won a new set of parents and
they were loving and supportive even
more so after they discovered that his
strength speed and that whole flying
thing was not of this earth no matter
what situation kent would find himself
in or who he wound up battling he always
had a home in smallville thanks to ma
and park kent as for bruce wayne his
lottery win was a little more
literal his family was loaded so once he
set his sights on fighting crime he had
all the resources at this earth and
maybe some other planets could provide
at his disposal plus the butler that
brings him three square meals a day it's
like having a chili's right in your home
if the chili's bartender would also help
you build the batcave and was really
good at keeping secrets
superman could also fly home to talk
with his mom but batman having a
confidant like alfred at the ready was
essential for his development
elf which is what i would call him
enough from the clown understood the
pain felt by this kid and was always
there to gently steer him in the right
direction but clark found himself a gal
pal he was mighty sweet on louis lane
has been played by everyone from margot
kidder to kate bosworth to amy adams on
the big screen and shout out to terry
hatcher and lois is the perfect
companion for both clark and superman
any more at home like you uh not really
no
but if we're looking at this round as
whose origin story is more exciting or
tragic or emotional we might assume it's
bruce wayne simply because we were right
there to witness these events time and
time again but need i remind you again
cow elves planet blew up
[Music]
most kids get upset when they move out
and their parents turn their room into
the peloton gym cal's got no home and he
was just the little infant at least
bruce was able to bathe and wipe himself
by the time his parents ate it you think
you know everything about me don't you
it's also a tremendous world building
for a film franchise to give us a peek
as to what a super alien's homeworld was
like i was particularly impressed with
zack snyder's powerful opening sequence
in man of steel that shows the beauty
that krypton held juxtaposed against the
corruption it had fallen prey to bruce's
rents getting axed is a clear indication
that someone needs to clean up gotham
city but seeing superman's home world
makes us wonder if that fate could one
day befall us earthlings a day of
reckoning is coming both the man of
steel and the caped crusader have origin
stories that rival that of anyone in
fiction in terms of scope depth emotion
pure violence but i'm giving the nod
here to superman he lost his people and
gained a sense of purpose once he landed
on earth we took him in and as a result
he saves us when we're falling from
buildings especially if we're an
attractive reporter for the day we plant
it soups gets the win here and is
finally on the board it's bruce 2 clark
1. you should not pick a fight with this
person round 4 dastardly deeds
it's neat to have a compelling yarn to
spin as to why you became a superhero
but once you did who was your
competition what were their nefarious
plans and how did you thwart them and
most of all how many oscars did all
those nerdwells have on their shelves
when it comes to villains we have two
all-time greats that debuted on the big
screen at the exact same time as their
more heroic counterparts gene hackman's
lex luthor and jack nicholson's joker
will they get a load of me
those two guys have no less than five
academy award wins between them doesn't
that give you a kind of a um a shudder
of
electricity through you to be in the
same room with me and then heath ledger
would win an oscar for playing the joker
of the dark knight if you're good at
something never do it for free currently
we have jesse eisenberg as lex luthor in
superman big screen lore i love bringing
people together but let's also look back
and give some love to the original otis
lex luthor's bumbling henchman played by
acting great ned beatty and who could
forget superman three we had richard
pryor in there it's not the best
superman movie but richard freaking
pryor batman seems to have the advantage
as far as famous foils after all arkham
asylum is a big place with lots of
corners and the ability to house
horrible people like the riddler the
penguin poison ivy and mr freeze to name
a few i'll toss catwoman in the mix as
well
thanks but more so when lee merriweather
or michelle pfeiffer played the part
you're overpaid hit the road
and hathaway's version is more out for
her own interest than anything else
which is kind of how real-life cats are
am i right meows but if batman has the
name power superman's enemies have more
ambitious goals batman's main
antagonists generally just want to wrest
control of gotham city for themselves
even bane played by tom hardy showed up
to gotham blew up a bunch of bridges and
isolated the metropolis now there was a
nuke involved that could have gone off
but gotham was again ground zero and the
league of shadows is a unit they took
care of rome and constantinople in their
millennia old history but they really
took their time before falling a city
like a thousand years there's being
patient and then there's being league of
shadows patient superman has to deal
with entities who don't want to wreck a
city or even a country they want to
destroy worlds just ask general zod
whether it's terence stamp or michael
shannon playing them in the movie
theater the fate of our planet is always
at stake when they show up where did you
train
on a [ __ ] the only time batman has
really had to worry about humanity
outside of his own town is when he teams
up with superman and the zack snyder
justice league or the the justice league
in the zach i like both cuts but if it
was truly zach's justice league couldn't
we at least had one of those talking
gahul owls i love those things they're
so cute but vicious bane broke batman's
back and doomsday killed superman
according to the comics his enemies
aren't concerned with funny zingers or
convoluted riddles riddle me this
they want blood and lots of it and in a
cruel twist of irony here they actually
help superman win this round the stakes
are higher and anything they lack in
personality or their ability to shuffle
a deck of cards is made up for it by
their sheer will to end all life as we
know it without batman gotham city's
tourist apartment would shut down
without superman
we're not around to enjoy a plus
programming like versus you're fired
point goes to the action comics guy and
we got us a tied ball game heading into
the final round i'll rend you
lem from lam and now it's time for the
wild card round social impact it all
comes down to this and if you think
social impact isn't important let me
remind you this isn't about the photo
ops that superman has with kids or the
charity work that the wayne foundation
does in fact this might be the single
most important aspect of any fictional
superhero because this round asks the
question what effect of you a fake
individual had on us real people in a
real matrix sorry well i think i took
the wrong pillar well you know how it is
mr fox you're out at night looking for
kicks someone's passing around the
weaponized to loosen the jacks you're
not supposed to take the it's the blue
one i should okay i know the truth
there's no going back for starters let's
go right back to the beginning superman
in 1978 gets a big early leg up on
batman because it was a comic book hero
film that worked for everyone batman in
the 60s was a campy kids show although
that decision was made after a more
adult-themed pilot bombed with test
audiences if batman 1966 showed that
these properties might be making money
superman proved the hypothesis but then
kind of hogged all the green cheddar for
himself for all the impact the og
superman had on the movie-making
industry it would be another 11 years
before a superhero sorted the cineplex
in the same way and yeah that guy was
batman
gives a feller a good feeling to know
they're up there doing their job batman
1989 showed us what to do with an origin
story even if it deviated from the
comics batman returns though it earned
its 80 on the tomato meter also reminded
us of the risks of getting too dark or
wacky or burtony making a follow-up even
though it did perform incredibly well at
the box office if parents were mad about
that film's adult themes batman forever
over-corrected in the other direction
whereas the bat movies kept showing us
exactly what to do and what not to do
christopher reeve's superman franchise
went how most of them do it saw
diminishing returns and ended with a
thud barely heard by anyone without
fourth film and as much as i despised
batman and robin then and don't even
enjoy hate watching it today in an odd
way batman and robin is one of the most
important comic book based films ever
ever
why because it ran batman into the
ground in such a spectacularly awful
obvious gloriously bad fashion that it
acted as the polar opposite of superman
iv with the quest for peace we were just
kind of exhausted and said okay no more
superman stop don't do it the people
with batman and robin we used more evil
words like ruin and end and dead and
because it was such a terrible outing it
set the stage for a complete reboot not
seen
since really ever batman 1989 had more
than 20 years to reconstruct the whiz
bang pow adam west cape crusader but in
2005 when we were still licking our
wounded bat cheeks christopher nolan
swooped in and delivered the vengeful
justice we all knew we wanted we just
didn't know how to go about getting it i
swear to god swear to me batman begins
completed the phoenix ashes cycle and
set the path for superman to return the
next year and for iron man to have his
own compelling origin story in 2008 the
dark knight's contribution to society
can be witnessed by a glimpse into the
ivory tower of hollywood elite heath
ledger winning a posthumous award for
playing a batman villain was a landmark
achievement but just as much was what
didn't happen at the oscars ceremony the
film itself was snubbed for a best
picture nomination and the ensuing
outcry resulted in the academy allowing
for twice as many best picture
candidates the varied next year i do
want to give superman the movie or the
motion picture depending on what poster
you're looking at it's roses too as it
did garner three oscar nominations for
sound music and editing and won a
special achievement award for its
groundbreaking visual effects yet while
it's oscar winner marlon brando wasn't
really invested in being in the movie at
all today a-listers are all the rage in
sinking their fangs into a juicy comic
book movie part yes that one was
literally for you jared leto's joker now
morbius i'm excited superman stands as a
symbol of hope and also remains the
first big time comic book film
blockbuster to appeal to the masses but
batman has been setting trends followed
by every major studio since that summer
in 1989 when he was in sold out theaters
the prince soundtrack was all over the
radio and there was a scarcity of basic
black t-shirts because so many
entrepreneurs were making and selling
knock-off bat merch as yogurt famously
said merchandising fans didn't initially
like the michael keaton casting news
thus they added over 50 000 signatures
to a petition long before change.org
made everyone think they could remake
the last jedi and batman the animated
series is hailed as one of the greatest
tv series period thanks in large part to
the vocal talents of one of the all-time
best kevin conroy superman might be more
pure of heart and stand for the ideal
version of us all but as far as impact
and legacy batman has done more for
hollywood's perception of superheroes
and for the comic book industry's
perception of the consumer than any
single character before or since and for
that it is batman who gets the win in
the social impact round thus giving him
the match three to two you really are
quite bright just pissed what people's
thing look this could have gone either
way but at the end of the day batman
kind of slept with superman's mom
sorta so ben affleck obviously played
bruce wayne slash batman but he also
starred as george reeves in a film
called hollywoodland reeves played
superman on tv and in the movie he is an
affair with diane lane's character diane
lane would go on to play martha kent so
superman
is in a tough spot either batman hooked
up with your mom
or you did i have so many questions
there's no good way out of this for him
but i find superman now justified in
ripping the hood off the batmobile well
that does it for this epic edition of
versus and remember it's just my opinion
hit me up on social media at mark ellis
live with your tig and keep checking
back here at rotten tomatoes for all the
latest and greatest in the world of
movies tv and beyond thanks for watching
i'm mark ellis and i think i will get
drive-through
you